with more on how the white house is
responding to all this wijajang joins us
from the white house wija good morning
good morning to you brad and good
morning to everybody president biden had
a phone call with british prime minister
boris johnson monday afternoon hoping to
hash out a diplomatic solution but they
are very realistic about what this
russian aggression could mean these two
leaders also talked about beefing up
security on nato's eastern flank and
vowed once again to take severe action
against russia if it attacks
although lawmakers on capitol hill have
yet to reach a consensus on a sanctions
package they are still trying to work
that out as well now yesterday national
security adviser jake sullivan briefed
senators about the situation both
democrats and republicans expressed
concerns afterward agreeing that russia
is prepared to invade and that the
situation is a dangerous one today
defense secretary lloyd austin heads to
lithuania poland and belgium where he
will attend a nato defense meeting he
also plans to visit u.s troops if russia
invades ukraine the u.s is considering
providing a 1 billion loan to help
secure the ukrainian economy they are
also talking to several regions about
the natural gas supply in case of a
major disruption michelle
all right weeja thank you